all right so can we curse
your first thing that you asked
the time
[Laughter]
what's
[Music]
light
it's like
the mixture between iop and iop after
dark
right
really
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
can we curse
we are back for the patreons for the
members all at all kind of sort of solve
a little bit
you don't want to do stuff for community
shout out to lord addict who is making
this happen behind the scenes getting
the community involved so we're going to
send it off man y'all can introduce your
damn self do i introduce you all today
don't even get an intro
you know you know who we are you know we
don't really have the intro like it's
just like look we're we're here to
answer the question with the community
we want yeah i know a lot of you want to
get to know us more on a personal level
that's not gaming related so we made
this platform what to give you uh
people would consider this pizza fiasco
you guys are doing on twitter
i gotta go
[Laughter]
he's like yeah i know nothing about me
yes sir we're going to start off with
these questions big shout out to
everyone in the realm who submitted
questions obviously we couldn't get to
all of them we have about 10 today that
we're going to get to so big shout out
to you guys so we're going to start out
with the first question and that comes
from sifu poetic x initiative i love
that name
so the question is is if each of you had
a chance to pitch a game
from design art style mechanics and
story content
what would your respective games look
play
and be named
who said no
yeah
oh add it go i gotta go
i would want coalition to make a spartan
lock third-person action adventure
with the gory like as gory as gears gets
tooking play no actually not spartan law
i would want because there there's a
the very first arbiter
he he like defined and he killed like
like thousands of people i want it to be
in his place on how the arbiter got his
name and it's like a gory thing he's got
the energy sword like cutting people's
limbs off and stuff like you know like i
want that like that that cover shooter
where the arbiter just reaches his big
long reachy arm over grabs them like
like i think that you know because i've
always felt like coalition can make a
really good
you know cover shooter halo games
man
all right all right that's that um
i like this one all right yeah yeah yeah
all right all right so i want namco to
uh
to get with the guy who made uh
uh shaolin versus wu-tang oh oh you
stole oh my god
straight up stole my wow
[Laughter]
wow
[Laughter]
i'm gonna do it
[Laughter]
but um i i want it i want it in the vein
of uh
actual
or karate film like because i thought
namco really was in the story telling
when it came to the uh the the fighting
mechanics but what separated them from
virtual fighters was the actual
uh thought of how they uh entered the
combat realm with the one arm
uh you know you know each arm is an
individual button which is the
individual button and then you know the
grab mechanics and stuff from there and
everything flowed from that aspect of
you know arm arm leg late and
i would love that developer that does
the you know the the wu tang versus
shaolin
to merge with namco with all their
fighting knowledge their hit detection
their ability to take an engine and uh
do it in unreal engine five oh my
god
so but i want it done in the shaw
brothers style all right so that's the
same way that they have all that music
and all that rich history uh with the wu
tang versus charlotte i thought that guy
really understood what channel five was
about yeah what uh what what that whole
driving movie theater was was the run
run shaw run me shaw shawn films that
whole era yeah and i want namco to bring
their experience their graphic
out there
the way the fighters just need a team
right and i wanted to be called uh wu
tang versus the world
um
and i i got just goosebumps that's a
very strong name yeah because you know
that incumbents because they they do
have that movie but that that encompass
uh all those movies like snake and eagle
shadow uh you know stuff like that you
know and i don't actually get licensed
bruce lee and stuff like that these
licensed guys named to get these guys
paid and stuff like that but
interaction wise when a character comes
up to another character and let's say
they did have interaction and then he
said movie they say they catch line from
that movie
you know like you know we're trying to
get that yeah
you know because we have we have the the
space and stuff like that to get that
stuff done
i just want that fighting game on that
type of level with destructible
environments like he just blow the
budget like but
this is my fantasy
and then i want it to have world
tournament links like so how you know
street fighter 5 on the playstation has
the ability to have the world tournament
links and stuff like that and everybody
can actually stream in and a crowd the
crowd could like
where you were with your fight
like oh my god
i'm down for that i'm down for that
that's the best
maz is all pretty simple you already
know um
ninja theory
right
unreal engine 5
i want like super high graphical
fidelity
third person over the shoulder but i
want
the return of shinobi right i want like
the some i want like some narrative joe
musashi behind the music you know what
i'm saying and and you get a personal
thing with them because as much as i
like it and i want it to be action i do
wanted some stealth elements i do want
some stuff elements but obviously i
should know more action you know what
i'm saying fast paced whatever whatever
so do that
um not open worlds i don't want open
world i want hub world so this way it's
a more contained story whatever
yeah i want like the hub i like hubble i
think you could do linear wide yeah i
don't want everything you got ghosts and
all that for that like so you know i
like like them to be uh driven into one
area or whatever and the story elevate
from there exactly you know what i'm
saying and this they've never really
sega's never really went into the
character deeply you know what i'm
saying and that's the thing so i think
if you tell a personal story with him
and then the organization neo-z or
whatever all that and get behind him on
that and like who is joe masashi or
whatever maybe you implement you know
shadow there whatever like history or
little historical references from the
other games
good to go but i have to have ninja
theory do it like just i i like they i
know they come any work but i like even
the way it looked when it's the dudes
come through it come out come at senua
you know what i'm saying and thing it is
very i mean you haven't you you remember
how uh was it not hellblade do you
remember
heavenly sword yes yes
and yeah just it's it's action-oriented
heavenly sword wow that's an amazing
game yeah yeah i actually saw jack move
playing
like it was kind of like
the the concept of that was weird yeah
that's besides the point yeah well
that's pretty much it but what you guys
saw
oh
my god i said that
but just to expand on that more because
again again my fantasy there's never
been a fighting game
that that
takes it to the level what are you about
to say so the level of realism and depth
that
where
you you can act you get injured during
the fight and you fight injured and the
injury just isn't some superficial thing
like if you play more
yeah they got games like that wasn't
there like an arcade like um
like yeah
i think that's what it's called and your
arm you you hop around like yeah
really really yeah i don't remember oh
he know
that's crazy i don't remember it that's
crazy so anyway that's right it flex
that brain
obviously it wasn't good enough so let's
do this again
what's it called attic the deli is what
the deadliest warriors yes i think
that's it
again
we need a fighting game uh
developer with the expertise of a band
dynamical to to really tackle this and i
wanted
i wanted just story wise i wanted to
have that feeling of the the best
moments of like a ghost of tsushima
where it does feel like a movie where
you have those those instances where
it's like you you you go back and you
look at the scene and it's like oh my
god this is the scene from a movie yeah
and i want it to be both hand-to-hand
based and i wanted to be both and
weapon-based as well because i remember
bushido blade the tension in bushido
blade as you're standing
face-to-face with your opponent and you
both know
one shot will do it and
again back in the ps1 days to think
about a game that was able to convey
that sort of tension yeah they did it
was crazy and nobody's ever tried to do
it since nobody's experimented with
probably a reason for that
it isn't right it isn't just it is the
most exciting moment-to-moment game play
but the amount of strategy involved in
that obviously it never really took the
chance to expand on it although two is a
big leap over one right
but that's what i want i want to see a
modern day fighter that implements all
of those things and makes it as
realistic as possible and again
i would love
am2 to get in on it oh bandai namco
because all of them have done bits and
pieces of that but again you kind of
arcadified it and you gamify it a little
bit obviously because like i hadn't said
there's certain things that just over
the long haul don't appeal
but i mean again pie in the sky that's
what i want to see
i like it
all right number two hold on it's like
my phone closed are you good
messing up man the city messing at one
job
the set our second is from
shroom kingdom
okay what is your favorite single-player
third-person gaming experience story
mine is probably max payne i remember
playing it as a child why were you
playing that as a child and getting
engrossed in its tragedy
i can't believe i was probably around 12
years old when i played that damn
him saying he played a game you
shouldn't have played
you know somebody but there's probably a
reason he's watching us because he
played that game
true a
what is this grand theft auto
it's a mickey mouse game
two of those
dudes
i
i've always enjoyed like i used to be a
huge uh splinter cell person
and i remember like probably like
the biggest moment i remember in like in
those type of games is i i was remember
playing like splinter cell conviction
and like you uh when you find out your
daughter
it it like they captured herself
i mean the game's like 20 years old
i mean it is what it is like
we ain't going into the spoiling thing
but it's like i remember like first off
he asked for experiences okay i'm going
what what the experience was playing in
great detail so
i remember like like the the epicness of
like because
in in splinters like eventually you got
like two head shots like where you
simultaneously kill two people but when
that particular moment happened you can
light them up like a christmas tree like
all of them you could kill them all like
and they would come in there like you'd
sit there you kill like a whole group of
them and then they'd come in for the
silly
they just cost you like you could do
them all again you could do them all
again you could do them all again and
that that always like
remembered straight i remember because
they had they had a co-op campaign for
that too
he's starting to worry me
like his first two joints has been some
real murder man
yeah i like that
and i think like when it comes to
convention like when you play the co-op
multiplayer
like obviously spoiler like you get to
the end and they make you fight each
other yeah
like i i haven't really seen companies
do stuff like that like really make you
work things out as a co-op experience of
two or more people and then you get to
the end of now you gotta kill each other
yeah yeah they never play double dragons
sir yeah
you killed me because i couldn't kill my
homie
i found out she was police
he was a rat i was like dawg man i made
jack mac with this dude in the toilet
bowl and he gonna
to affect me in that manner
ever that i'm quivering like a baby
holding a controller with tears in my
eyes like okay so the last of us won i
played through it
it was cool the story was nice
and you know the dlc was good you know
the in the dlc they was able to approach
a lot of um unconventional
unconventional norms that we have like
quieted uh conversations and they did
that in the dlc matter because they
wanted to see if the that group was uh
receptive to uh these type of stories
being told
what they did was they didn't do
the and i felt that was like a coward
way out um because
they they wanted to see what that first
property would be received as when they
had these stories because
conceptually wise these stories were
there on the board if you got a dlc
in the main story the last of us too
they addressed
a lot of
uh male female
role reversals
uh uh sexual um
confusion
uh sexual identity
uh
uh norms in society uh as far as
uh
dogmas that we are stuck with uh that we
are we inherit from our parents uh
what will happen in a community that has
devolved the structure what we we will
turn into
our base problems uh man is its own
worst enemy uh the level of fear and
tension that you had when you saw a new
group of people that you didn't know
what was going on was absolutely insane
and then to have a character that i
absolutely hated to turn into the
character that i i loved and i wanted to
protect the most
it's insane because i haven't seen that
since you know attic had me turned on to
naruto in uh
in the ways that she can absolutely hate
a single character to his last cell and
then to hear his story and to see his
story and to have that oh i want to hug
him
oh my god now i understand and it and it
teaches you and i thought this game was
a very
good teachable moment
to whoever stuck around to the end
whoever put the prejudices to the side
and i i think is certain moments in that
game that test your character
opposed to just testing your thought
process on how to solve a puzzle it was
it was it was like a life simulator in
the de-evolution of the human uh psyche
and that game
has it will always stand as the
strongest
story told game that i've ever
experienced
because of the un
relenting uh strength that neil
druckmann and his team had
to bring and tell that story
and don't shy away from anything
it's just everything was there and then
if you received it you received it but i
really that's that's my game that's
absolutely available i got to put neal
junction strength in quotations
yeah it's hard to tap kick i go up but
um
mass effect series just as the trilogy
as a whole you know obviously me and saw
feel the way we feel about which one is
best but at the end of the day
i think the third one's best he thinks
the second one yeah he likes the first
one but what's great about it is all all
of us right we have our particular one
right that that we resonate with
here we
what it points to is the fact that all
three are great and then yeah yeah and
they just appeal to different people
differently uh you know you can't really
definitely the weakest
ten years in hindsight oh god let's not
devolve this into something else but
like i was saying oh the thing about it
is again you got the new generation you
got us you know everybody you know
playing this thing again but the thing i
realized is i think i mean you had this
conversation which is like still to this
day there is no game that carries your
journey from
game to game and for the most part every
major
story beat and consequence there's some
nuance of it of what you did the impact
of what you did in a prior game to build
up to the moment now you can say what
you want to say about the ending and
that's fine but it was so ambitious for
his time to do what it did and to be
honest the writing pads right
and obviously the evolution of paragon
and renegade and the type of character
you want to be obviously the space opera
and stuff like that but another thing i
go a lot you know obviously it's not as
deep as you know what king is talking
about with the last of us as far as um
well you know personal relationships but
yeah but the thing it did
is
i don't remember really like romancing
characters in games right like where you
like yo this is and then based on what
you do at the time you do it can affect
other people or other people feel away
or what you know it like the whole yard
thing
um
tally
remember i went so above and beyond to
like keep this chick good
and i remember there's a point where
where legion was tripping yeah and i'm
sitting there i don't know what to do
like i'm generally just panicking
so i'm thinking everything's fine i
think i calm the situation down and then
it just because i like legion i want to
keep him alive and then tyler's like nah
this two got to go look
down
what i like about it too is it had
that's all racial like alien racial
prejudices built this you don't say you
know you can't trust them voters yeah no
you can't you don't say like the grogans
the best sci-fi always sort of is a
mirror image of what we live
right yeah it's just a matter of seeing
it in a different context but it allows
us to look at the sometimes it's
difficult to look inward and as a human
being we're like damn we suck sometimes
we really do
and when you see it projected onto
something else it's a little bit easier
to sort of swallow per se
yeah and even even the the choices are
wrap up the even the choices with the
human race right being introduced as
like the last people to the table right
yeah so we always think that we're high
exactly
yes to notice like the the the big the
big dudes i thought the big dude story
where they had to kill off their whole
yeah race that was crazy and you know
what's crazy it's like there were
certain scenarios where i actually
really really cared about like the jfk
thing i was at that point by the third
one as i don't care what happens we
getting this thing fixed yeah yeah yeah
i don't care what the repercussions are
we getting this fixed and
then like then they give you that that
moment that where in order to fix you
you got to lose someone else i'm like
do i really want to give it a moment
because it it made me care about
characters in gaming so that's pretty
pretty much it obviously you know king
we seen the evolution last of us you see
where it took us there but yeah but that
like you're saying um
it was
the
like sovereign said the reflection of
the inward mirror you know outward
projected onto the screen
it was asking questions of a child and
children um because we were young when
we got this and our minds are developing
and we're seeing uh prejudices and and
if you put
the human another human in front of that
prejudice and you just change the color
right it's just like wow makes you step
back
are you going to kill that whole nation
their family stuff like that or are you
going to listen to this side and it was
a lot of politics that played yeah
that i think that game showed me the
structure of the roman uh thought
process more than any game when it came
to uh
politics and how did you move with the
council
yes
you know what made me realize king
right that i'm secretly a sociopath
[Laughter]
what you got man i mean you know what
mine are it's just it's red dead and red
dead too oh god
next question
yeah
please enlighten me
because i had a conversation i'm a fraud
when it comes to red dead and i'm not
even gonna sit here and lie i start
playing them and then i got that
squirrel dog looking like squirrel
king there's probably a reason that
you're a pro
today i realized what uh cog was talking
about is right i love hub world yeah i
love go do your mission come back hub
world okay go pick your mission go back
do hub world right when i get tossed
into the world to do anything yeah nine
times out of ten i'm not finishing it
yeah and i i don't know i like i like
open world
that
is set for hub world going throughout
the game like what's up you have certain
parts of the map that get unlocked yeah
and it becomes like your center like
more and more like that like dying light
yeah like you know i like stuff like
that like i don't like games that like
you pop out the gate and then it's like
you can go anywhere they don't even
really tell like
like give you any remotes of like where
you should do what you should do like i
think i've grown away from stuff like
that like the only game i can really
think about that's like maybe skyrim now
but you know they had a lot of focusing
on what you do and what you don't do in
that too so yeah so solve educate us
i mean we read that right that came out
2010 right and at that point in my life
i'm like i'm not playing any kind of
cowboy game i'm not into this i'm not
playing this um so 2010 i didn't touch
it what went wrong
how did i go astray after that so uh
2012 for me
2012 and into and 2013 were were kind of
transformative years for me this is i'm
getting ready to get married for the
second time um
my job stuff is changing and it's like
it's one of those things where it's like
you know what i've heard so damn much
about this game people still keep
talking about this game i need to sit
down and play get over myself
so as it turns out i start playing it
basically at the same time the gta 5 is
out so i have these two different rock
star games and two different approaches
to open world that i'm playing
simultaneously
and for me
what what sort of set red dead apart
from rob from
gta
is just that idea of conveying feeling
and thought just through environment
just
literally
just the sounds around you like the the
hues of the color like i always talk
about that moment when i was in the
desert by my damn self and the sun is
setting on the horizon you see like that
bright like burning red in the horizon
and you're just chilling on your horse
and the music kind of goes in line with
it and i'm like wow like i've never been
in a game where it it makes me
experience this and makes me feel like
i'm there
you know there have been other games
like again like ocarina of time like i
was so engrossed in that game but at the
same time i was more engrossed at how
beautiful it looked for the time right
than the world it was sort of creating
for me right i was kind of caught up in
the tech or whatever this i'm older i'm
getting i'm going into another phase of
my life and i was just happy to be
sitting there on the couch experiencing
that and mind you i'm experiencing it in
a big a huge tv headset on lights off
total oh that's song
yeah that's fantastic so
for me it just to date there still isn't
a game that hasn't it doesn't gross me
in that way they've been they've been
games that i've i've been into that have
kind of captured my attention like we
talked about dead space like playing
dead space with the damn lights off and
everything you know yeah that's an
experience unto itself exactly those
things do that
this is one where it was just a placid
tranquil thing and at any moment it
could go haywire as well
it could do all of those things that
game has that range where it can give
you the action moments especially the
first one the first one is much more of
a game where the second one is much more
of an experience like they expanded on
that in a way that
doesn't appeal to everybody who liked
the gaminess of the first game right so
it to me that that's
i just love disappearing into those
moments because again
my life changed considerably
right right after that so i don't have
time to really experience those games in
the same way even read that too even
right there too like i'll have my
headphones on and playing it and i see
my wife is looking at me like
i gotta tell you something i gotta say
like you're breaking it for me
it's absolutely that and no other game
has done that to me in my opinion better
you know i was done with that game
when i got he had his moment at it yeah
because the bear ran so i got back on my
horse i ran back after it i got off went
to shoot him
and my gun was on my horse and i was
like
i got all i didn't put my gun on the
horse like
like so
then the bear ate me
all right next question hold on a second
next question comes from randy rhodes
what are your guys favorite albums of
the year so far
mine are call me
uh if you get lost by tyler the creator
i thought he was saying call me maybe it
was like
wait a second what year is it
my third question is
what game is solved playing
yeah that was my third but it's cool
he's got the list that he's got a
different list
in a different order in a different
order yeah yeah okay i know because i
was the same way i was like wait a
minute we ain't ready for that
i gave him the list i had the name so he
could find that if you want me to do it
in that order i'll jump to it okay
whatever y'all want to do
about what i'm prepared for okay guys
all right so we got [ __ ] j
yes what game is sob playing the most
not destiny
and what game is his most anticipated
story game for this year that's gonna be
a quick question this is yeah so um
the game that i'm playing i don't get to
play as many games as i would like to so
i don't play a lot of stuff
um so
honestly what i'm playing the most of is
probably on my switch because it's
always with me and i've been playing
that game ender lilius
and that's kind of like a metroidvania
in which like you're essentially you're
you're a small girl that's like the
descendant of this like holy priestess
but the girl doesn't have any actual
powers
so um
basically you're you're you're tasked
with removing this
light this blight from the world right
and uh there are there are people that
have been tasked to protect you they've
been overcome by the blight and when you
beat them in combat they now become your
protectors so you have all of these
powers at your disposal of these people
that you've defeated and they're the
ones that actually do the combat but you
actually controlled little priestess or
whatever um it's cool uh it's a
metroidvania the combat is pretty cool
especially the boss fights are are very
interesting so i've been playing that um
i jumped back into hades again obviously
on the on the series x a little made me
want to go back to the switch version as
well and play um hades is just that good
um and that's pretty much it now the
thing that i was most excited for story
wise this year
is 12 minutes
i wish we would discuss and we'll
discuss that
my apologies i will say that it
sometimes that's not the question we're
talking about this yeah yes it's that's
our iop in the realm okay one pm easter
egg sorry guys but
alex found out alex brown tomorrow yeah
yeah
all right next question is from dano
which upcoming games that have been
announced for this year do you believe
will still get delayed and by how much
would it mind a prediction date
oh okay so i can't say jay barry knees
jay barneys will not be delayed
i think everything comes out that that's
supposed to come out um
from my perspective that's on the slate
from microsoft that it's on the slate
from sony uh
nintendo
with what just happened with halo that's
definitely not getting delayed now
um so um
me uh
uh
i would i would have went with horizon
and and we already got the truth to that
um so i think everything is pretty much
close to schedule because a lot of these
games remember are holdouts from either
last year or earlier in this year yeah
and they're just buttoning up and
tightening up things so maybe things
move when they started giving dates
maybe they move to a couple of days out
or a week or two out
but um
every game was subject to moving yeah
like uh we seen with the kima what's
that game for the playstation with the
lucina yeah right that game was moved
for two weeks or something like that so
uh every game is subject to move in that
same two-week space but i think these
guys the developers and uh the you know
the manufacturers they they are all
pretty much locked in on their dates so
i don't think we see any big major like
fallbacks like a call of duty or
something like that you know so no i i
don't know atticu
i think dying like two might get pushed
back out of 20 yeah yeah
i think there's a chance it it's
probably coming out this in december but
like king said i feel like a lot of
these games
they like the core part of their
development was before the pandemic so
they didn't get hit with the two too
hard they got hit with it obviously but
i feel like a lot of the you know the
big parts of the development process was
before the pandemic got in its its core
and so i don't think they're gonna hit
with it but
i do think that dying like two out of
everything because it's had a lot more
of an issue in terms of development
cycles so i do think it might get pushed
back to 2022 maybe like
february march
okay okay okay i'll jump in um i got two
something um
so from the third party showcase that uh
they did that didn't show a lot of
gameplay um the fax box i think the two
that i'm wearing i hope i'm wrong with
gamescom
was um no actually um bright memory
infinite
and xo mecca and i'm like where are
those remember exo mecca was the big
battle royal donald
trump woman's looking thing
and i'm ray to me it was one of the best
looking joints i've ever seen just
graphically remember the time he's like
yo we want to see what the x could do
and then of that and i'm like oh that's
what the ex could do right there and i
was looking at that bright memory
regardless of the first one that came
from what is it
messed me up yeah cause you thought that
was it you was like oh no and i saw a
kid smooth playing it i
i was like that's that's the early joint
but i just think those two are very
very like graphical showcases of the
system
and i'm just like damn we haven't heard
from so hopefully games gone but if not
i could see like a first quarter
you know 2022 type situation but i hope
i'm wrong hopefully we get what what
happened to those games but what you
guys saw
yeah for me i got a couple um
first
guardians of the galaxy because they
gave it a date right off the brip like
off the rip and it looks like it needs
to be delayed two years
there's things about the yeah exactly
it's like obviously they've been working
on it for a long time
um not long enough
yeah but it does sort of feel like you
know like they haven't said much more
other than that break big breakdown we
got when they announced it initially and
that's about it but like like alex said
there's just certain things that still
felt like they needed work and the fact
that when you come out with a date
immediately and we haven't seen any of
the game beforehand
you know you know
i think that game was an expansion for
the all for the marvel game it feel like
a little bit yeah it's an expansion for
this
game
i think they said oh we got to
disassociate ourselves
he was the character
they
this game's so hot let's make another
game with uh
with other stuff let's not put it with
us let's make another game
maybe it's got better chance with it
yeah
and then after that another one from the
showcase from the xbox showcase was
chorus
we haven't heard i forgot about that
it's like all of these games remember
all these games had 20 21 releases yeah
third party case quiet yeah they've been
very quiet
you're looking at smaller um studio type
of games um
i was i was thinking more blockbuster
type of stuff you know
you know smaller stuff
always
go into the ether then come back out at
the opportune time kind of almost when
it's ready to go right because i think
smaller
titles have to hit their nail on the
head um more so than like larger aaa
titles you got to think a lot of these
triple a towers have already been
delayed at least once so yes yeah
not a lot of chance
yeah so the last one for me is uh is
hollow knight silk song
i'm a big majority i'm a big
metroidvania dude so the hollow knight
is is like scottier so yeah i don't know
they haven't said much more about it
we'll see
um they will support i think somebody
had a blowout a couple of months back
one site i forgot what it was but yeah i
haven't heard anything else so it easily
could be pushed into 2022. yeah it's
crazy because i played that game at e3
what is that 2018. yeah we did that
hollow knight
was buying the little amiibos yeah
it was in the switch section
speaking of the amiibo thing that you
know how much they try to promote that
amiibo and that skyrocket sword that's
like crazy every time i oh you know you
could use the amiibo would the game be
advertising that
wow
what i love about that
is attic is a as a true dude like if he
plays something and he gets to that
point and he says he will text you no
matter what he did
yo you was right yeah he was like
a lie there was this one time i was in a
dungeon because with the amiibo you you
can go to the uh to the sky like easy
wait tell me you got the amiibo
what happened
is i i was deep in a temple
and i was like man if i had that amiibo
like i would have to go
like i was like
for the set for for the first time
having that switch i was like i wish i
had that damn
all right so next up we have michael
askew
oh skew lord
that's cute all right so he says
discovery's purchase of warner brothers
could be finalized as soon as q1 of
2022.
new ceo might want to shed some pounds
i got this too i think the door will be
open again for the game division to be
sold yes
i think king might be on one but i don't
know he may be different yeah look i
hope so uh hopefully i'll just you know
i hope so i hope they you know get sold
off the gaming stuff but um
netherrealm
um i want you
i want you and i got to have
like i really i really hope microsoft
does it because that to me
is the only [ __ ] in the armor that's
the only achilles heel you know i'm
sorry i know everybody killer mistake
but for the most part they don't outside
of that there's really nothing in the
fight to be honest with you like i think
it's a time-sensitive thing if they
don't jump on this fighter market
they're not going to have it
you just don't yep because where i'm at
is
you say what you want we i know king
clowns them with eve sony with evil but
that means a lot yeah like that's a huge
they've cornered the market as like the
fighting game system and to me microsoft
got to strike back you got if who
cornered the market because you didn't
say the name um sony okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah
oh my fault yeah yeah yeah sony
definitely got the market with that they
they've ingratiated themselves with the
fighting game community like you go to
evo you know how you know casuals are if
they see everything yeah it's like no
that's it's only there we already saw
the effects of the street fighter like
it was only there yeah yeah you know
what's funny too
i think microsoft low-key came together
with epic they're like yo we gonna push
sony into this cross play thing we're
gonna take that advantage away from them
but the thing about it is though if you
believe that rumor that jeff grubb just
put out that day there
grubby gruff said that the next thing
they're working on is is mk so it's not
a it's not a dc game right okay so
they're working on the next mk so if
that's in production at some level right
what happens then like do they finish
that game and then get sold off or yeah
that's gonna be the question i mean yeah
discover all right so they don't seem
like they want it they need to do it
discover it doesn't care about that it's
like uh um you know when you foreclose
on your home and you know the bank is
not don't care about becoming you know
property owners the bank wants money
right so discovery doesn't give you know
two apps about video games that's not
their thing their content is streaming
content that is consumable they want uh
warner brothers properties that whole
division is going to be sold off if it's
going to be sold off as a bundle if it's
going to be sold off as individual
assets going off and those are where the
developers come in from this is the
problem that you have when it goes into
individual developers being sold now
you're talking about people as
commodities because the developing
houses or individuals and people that
can come and go at any period of time
they have to have contracts that are
keeping them structured in place for a
certain period of time each company has
to have each employee that is tethered
to that company those those essential
employees that have set it to their
company for at least five years from
said purchase right then you have the in
um
unessential uh employees the the plug
and play employees that we always gripe
about that are you know that is actually
the heart and soul of it right that'd be
doing a day-to-day life
actually changes how the company dynamic
works uh hopefully those they can extend
contracts to them especially in this
cover time uh what i think might happen
is they're going to be sold in like
blockchains right so you will have uh
two companies being sold to one entity
two companies being sold to one entity
uh to consolidate that and to get those
uh you like pushed off instead of single
companies being sold the event of 10
cent having the problems that they're
having with the chinese government is uh
procuring them from acquiring new uh
companies and what i've noticed like in
a couple of games it just popped up uh
10 cents studio logo will pop up in the
beginning keep an eye out for that
because i've only seen that two times
and this is the second time that i've
saw that and that is them revealing
their selves
a little bit more um so i i really
honestly feel that tencent is no longer
a player in acquiring new studios
they're going to probably double down on
their studios and make their presence a
little bit more felt
in those studios that they do have so
it's only a couple of uh
men
companies that can actually purchase
these studios that will be available
microsoft is an ideal place for certain
studios like you're saying i have a
different thought i think sony purchases
another realms i think sony understands
where they are at with uh the evo i
think they understand where they are in
that community as the fighting community
right and i also think that as far as
the country roll thing and uh the
funimation thing
they really have the air to that anime
crowd so those material games and stuff
like that will be played in this uh
space that evil space and they're gonna
make their fighting they're gonna double
down on a fighting arm and they're going
to make their fighting on the strongest
arm and that way they can keep microsoft
at bay to be honest with you when it
comes to that because all the fighting
stuff will be on the playstation sony
platform yeah i think i'm only against
them it makes it i mean i can see you
going for just to finish what i was
saying before um
i think it's like
yeah i mean it makes sense that those
two
are in bed right it makes complete sense
i'm not disagreeing there like i just
feel like you know the way i look the
reason why i think it's more likely
microsoft could do it is because i
always feel sony doesn't get better
unless they've had a previous
relationship with you right
like they they tend to be like you know
they we going steady for a long time and
then all right all right insomnia okay
what's that like all right you know what
i'm saying like they usually
they don't generally just be like yo
something new you want to make sure you
loyal yeah like they want to have that
relationship so i mean i'm not saying it
makes sense it makes sense yeah you know
saying but my thing is i need microsoft
jump in there i i really need them
i like the big block i like the big
blockbuster aspect of it and boom
and and like i said they they're one of
the kings in the space you know what i'm
saying so but what's we'll see what
happens but either either scenario i
mean
which i got
yeah
go ahead
i just think that
the only company that's probably this
company's looking at them
i think they're going to get sold now
because there's a difference between
um warner brothers trying to make money
and discovery trying to just get rid of
them yeah yeah so i can't say prices are
going to drastically go down
and i think now you're going to see some
studios by them
and i can totally see sony buying one or
two of them because
like at the end of the day like
it's like you know
i wish i had the sound effect from like
the uh
the call of duty uh zombies it's like
fire yourself
when they cheat it makes you like okay
you know
you don't see people trying to kill
people at black friday for the same
thing that they wouldn't buy a day
before like i feel like i feel that dude
no doubt solve
listen i i definitely agree with you i
know it's all i'm going to say i agree
with you guys 100 percent that they i
don't know the discovery cares about
the well they've already said they don't
right so they don't care about the long
tail of game development and whatever
money they can make off of that they
want to make money as quickly as
possible right
um but
i i do i could see them trying to sort
of
figure out a way to keep some of these
developers not maybe the big names right
but the smaller names to make cash grab
smaller games based on these properties
right because if you think about all
these properties the warner brothers
properties you know harry potter like
stuff like that lego
these are ju these are cash cows so it's
a matter of them figuring out i don't
think that they're gonna sell those no
they're not selling the property right i
think they'll sell the studios not the
properties
they might be a little bit more loose or
something like mortal kombat maybe
because like even the last movie wasn't
really
because i don't think no one's people
might buy uh netherrealm without mortal
kombat but you're gonna have more
potential buyers of mortal kombat game
with it right and that's not that
actually that's the one i think they
would be willing to let go of like what
you said everything else obviously not
you're not getting batman you're getting
anything right that other property yeah
you got to look at that content that
they existingly have already to see if
any of that warner brothers stuff falls
in line with their content as far as
their gaming division and their ips
remember uh when we spoke to hogan these
dudes uh
those companies aren't as attractive
without those without those ips right
they're great developers
but again because they have control of
them
i could see them looking to sort of
manipulate some of those
some of those dev studios into making
these types of games um and keeping them
whether that they're able to do that or
not and the ones that are resistant to
it i see them trying to to sell to
king's point i really do what it sounded
like
is that's a field they're unfamiliar
with and they're not ruling to risk the
type of revenue that they have to invest
into it
potentially not get the money back
that's that's my the return on
investment is the biggest thing because
it has to be they have to put that money
there when's the last discovery game
that you've seen
you know and to to get a company to sync
you know millions of dollars into a
project that they're not familiar with
they're going to stick to something that
they can familiar with if they can get
money off an asset of purchasing and
then they can just shed the fat and then
get to what they're trying to do not to
deviate from where they are
i think discovery is in a whole
different wavelength opposed to
worrying about the future revenue
they'll be worrying about the immediate
loss
and you know and and thoughts of rev now
they're not if anything if they don't
sell i could see them
like becoming like a second party thing
with their ips like yo xbox you you want
to hate uh you want a harry potter game
we got a studio to make it and we'll
give you the license but you funding it
we ain't funny you funny here we go
we've been talking about netherrealm
what about a rock steady what about
where do you think these all right
that's where you're gonna go
where do you think these guys steady
even worth it without batman that batman
looked good batman
they basically they basically gave the
blueprint for the modern video game yeah
like the modern superhero video
superhero game yeah like
they gave the blueprint everyone's doing
it better than them now oh damn
the batmobile okay i get it i get the
batmobile but beyond that they haven't
done anything else right that how is
that my fault they ain't made
been at elder scrolls since 2011. i'm
going to say that's still the best rpg
in the world because they made a game
since 2011. yeah but is it does it take
away of the quality of elders girls
though
am i supposed to say that they just
forgot how to make
is is better than than the witcher
because they ain't made a game since
then since the witcher came out both of
them
what you're saying but again you're
saying that that somehow in that time
period they forgot how to make a game
like
how are we going to turn questions
together
all right
yeah we're going along yeah give me a
second
i said i'll be down here for an hour
yeah you already played everything
boy
okay
then we have pixel bit g
if machine games announces quake is
returning
who's hype and do you think it can do as
well as doom and wolfenstein i do
i do think it can it's coming back they
just put uh yeah
told this individual if you wanted to
pick another question he could because
he got announced but he never responded
so that's that's not the same as quake
coming back right he's talking about
quite coming back in the vein of doom
coming back into the yeah it's just a
matter of time it's going to hit
always that i don't feel like they they
would put the money and resources to
remaster if they i agree i agree like i
have a feeling this is the small project
the next yeah i agree this is the
engaged against interest
remastered yeah get you back in make you
feel you already things
if you pre-order you get this for a
bonus right and then they had linemen
out there
huge fail and then the machine when the
studio head what is it the studio guy
for machine games
his favorite game of all time is
bloviating about quake and they got him
on this project to me it's like
they setting it up like they said
you know you know what you know what i
do know king what that remake gonna be
on xbox oh yeah well yeah
i don't know i said this um i don't know
about that no i do oh you think you know
that not everything they have to remake
if they if they oh i'm [ __ ] i'm
thinking about the i'm full i'm thinking
about double i'm talking about like the
wolfenstein treatment yeah right doom
treatment yeah like that that next level
joint because
this is okay so quake people don't
really understand yeah educate me on
that i'm not a quaker so
was polygon
uh
master race crap like you dudes are
frauds like you made the pc terrorist
race dudes there's absolute frauds why
they fraud because they're terrorists
they're pc terrorists they're not fraud
they're elitist they try to hack like
you know their elite but that's you
i'm gonna tell you who should be the pc
master race guy we've did we've done
this right
with your voodoo cards
why
um it was the first polygon shooter
that was moving that fast like that
arena shoot out it was it was it it hit
all the bells and whistles and doom
wasn't that doom was like pixels
and it looked off this stuff was full 3d
and you had to have that that voodoo 3df
3dfx card um and we got it and we were
playing it and you could play it at a
decent clip and it was the first one and
it was successful i always thought um
they didn't trust their big ips like
wolfenstein or doom
and they made quake as a test bed and it
became so successful in that test
project and that's what that's why test
projects are always good
you don't use your main ip it's a test
product and then you say wow and it
actually takes off and when it does take
off it becomes an entity within itself
and i think quake now
that um
because you know we had quaker ringing
and stuff like that and that was really
good for xbox
um and this is kind of crazy it's coming
full circle
i think this quake is going to be nuts
and they're trying to explore
all the things that they can do so
you're going to get things that you
didn't see in doom done here things that
you didn't see in wolfenstein done here
because quake has always been the
experimental uh title and always brought
in that twitch feel that that real
kill them like that that whole racking
them up like you know that they're
shooting a grenade and jumping in and
shooting the laser and just running
through and just grabbing the shield it
was really fast it was really visceral
and i think that is probably one of
their best um titles and the fact is you
said uh machine um games yeah
is working on it i love this stuff so
yeah yeah yeah i'm i'm trying to get
into it i'll never really rock for one
before so it's completely new to me try
it on game pass i mean you're gonna get
in there and the graphic is gonna turn
for somebody who was there at the
beginning yeah to see this game running
that way
oh how is that
it's it's crazy because you spent damn
near 2500 on a pc to be able to run this
yeah
yeah exactly to be able to get some
frames out of it you know
it was the crisis of its time yeah
exactly
running at 60 on a switch like it's it's
kind of crazy crazy because you guys
remember what that was exactly okay 120
frames per second is mind-blowing yeah
you could have never achieved that
nah man it was it was it was one of
those things that you put together a
machine to play these games yes um and
and and with quakes specifically
quake was quake really was at the
forefront of the online multiplayer
space in
the pc space right because we're doomed
with doom you had you had death matches
and stuff with multiplayer stuff but a
lot of it was land and local yeah
online multiplayer it was really quake
that really started that that whole sort
of big thing and then with quake as well
quake was one of the first games that
was like
had rockstar status a little bit because
they had like um they had actual like
like music stars making music for it or
not
was it it kind of elevated the the
softworks team got you to like rock star
status the john romero's the john carmax
like stuff like that yeah
so it was just it was at the for like
like king said the 3d rendering like
that was the first time
the first time i ever heard the words
opengl i was like ah nah
it was it was it was something different
it was the beginning of what we know now
what we see yeah so to to bring quake
back i think king is right they have to
do
they have to be willing to be weird with
it right but they have to give it the
same love and care that they gave doom
and they gave wolfenstein meaning they
have to create a a story around it that
that matters i don't know they need to
necessarily create a protagonist that
matters in the way they did with like
like bj blaskowitz or something like
that but they do have to create a story
around it that matters while maintaining
the core and the heart of what quake
gameplay is which is quick twitch
shooting in a way that's different from
doom okay so i i'm just i'm glad they're
willing to do it i think
what i see now with all these arena
games like this split uh space thing
game and people was playing oh display
game yeah and um you have uh
you see them going back into that arena
type of shooting
in the halo
those games move slow compared to quake
yes like quake
is the epitome of speed just pure
all-out raw unadulterated speed and if
they can get that harness into the quake
the quake arena
fail back at it again and you just i'm i
really can't explain it more if you was
those i'm pretty sure that that game
gave more cataracts out than any game
that has ever been announced because if
you played that game for such a long
period of time you had to have eye drops
sitting right next to it
yeah it was like that it was like that
so what we got excited for that okay
next up okay now we're back to randy
rose oh yeah
what are your guys favorite albums of
the year so far might not call me if you
get lost by tyler the creator king's
disease two by nas and donda by kanye
west i know it's not officially official
yeah but the listening party was fired i
want addict to go first
[Laughter]
nothing there but i didn't know like
okay i know who kanye west is i know who
john the creator is like i liked like
like i i like
that that's all run away from kanye os
but like besides that like wait
definitely
like game music you listen to no it's
not even game music it's like i i i
listen to like a lot of different stuff
but it's not wrong no you're listening
to bach
what
that's all
cool i guess like i i listen to nf's new
album this show all right
thank you thank you thank you so much
there it goes
i didn't even listen to eminem's new
album this year
okay but
all right all right it's all from jesus
i'm just listen i think i'm more of a
fraud than anybody else here because i
honestly i am that dude that listens to
like new hip-hop and stuff like that and
i'm like it's not fair i'm the grumpy
old man
i'll be about grumpy here and so i'm
gonna be honest like i
my wife in spanish they call it fresita
really like you listen to like the like
the the the pop stuff the new whatever
is new right whether it be
whatever whatever's on the radio is what
i listen to i i don't really gravitate
to any specific type of music anymore
like i said that that is as far as i go
this year
nothing specific that i can identify as
this is a new album or whatever like
honestly like i i just don't i fell off
completely i used to be big into hip-hop
like yeah and they said obviously east
west and all that stuff back in the 90s
and early arts but
i just don't anymore so whatever catches
my eye whatever's good to work out to or
whatever
dude
listening to a little king disease too
i don't know so yeah so that that's it
for me nothing nothing special um all
right king me being you talking about us
all the time
the king disease too uh for me yeah i
can't say donda because um i'm waiting
for drake to drop his joint um i heard a
little snippets of that and gandalf is
not official you know kanye's trying to
fake out drake they playing a stupid
game i don't care about that um the j
cole album
i thought that j cole album was fire
like literally fire
uh
i thought nas took a step in the right
direction i think he matured as a uh
artist
i think he matured as a man um
to have a lot of features on his yes
that he doesn't normally steal my points
uh
the music hit in a different space
because mentally he's elevated
and um
in in your elevation
uh if if you don't fix your flaws
because i think his his last critically
acclaimed album was king disease one
and that was really a hymn centric uh
type of album yeah uh going into the
mind's eye of naz uh one of our like
greatest uh musicians
and
um king disease two was the evolution of
nas to to see his growth
as uh artist as a person
um as as what his vernacular actually if
you dissect the bars yeah and see where
he's at you have to really listen to the
album four or five times and actually
catch up certain things yeah
because sometimes uh bars just uh fly
right past you and then you were like oh
it is current with this stuff of really
really good stuff um
and j cole's album cool j cole the way
we consume music now we consume music in
such a weird way that we don't actually
sit down and listen to complete albums
any longer yeah
you know
like solving the same we become uh pop
heroes so whatever is popping on the
popular track
and we're consuming it that way and you
never get the album in this totality
like before we would get it we would
listen to
each track and we were oh that song is a
banger analyze it go back go back and
forth with it yeah so now how we consume
music is really disjointed and it takes
you out of the experience of of feeling
what the artist wanted to do with the
album so um the eminem album like uh
like attic was saying i thought his
album was really consistent for the
character he that he portrays himself to
be i don't think he's grown at all
i don't think he lost anything right but
i've always believed that eminem was
always the pinnacle of him
and he's never elevated past that he's
always been
that high watermark for himself but
there's never been any growth and it
hasn't been any degradation in it eminem
only has like serious growth when he's
going through some serious [ __ ] and he
doesn't really go through that like that
anymore so
yeah i think i think that any any artist
that's um
that's necessary for growth yeah i mean
you guys set all the points um musically
first i'm kind of where soft is at like
the days of me with the albums is kind
of over so it's kind of like you know
unless i really rock with you that's why
i mentioned king disease but other than
that it's usually attracts something
that hit me even if it's current and
it's new with the kids about like oh
this is cool i cool and i keep it moving
into attic's point like i do listen to a
lot like at the gym i can't listen to
hip-hop and stuff like i gotta not all
the time like i gotta listen especially
when i'm doing cardio i cannot listen to
him
you know i got i gotta have like
something even video games my dream is
techno music yeah
that keeps
you know the reason why that is right is
the rpms of the music rpms right yeah
we are energy right we are we buy right
we need that if
you
you get to that that place yeah your
body is elevating at that point
techno hits that for me
that's the thing good point good point
yeah so that's that before yeah like you
said it's definitely obviously nazis
joining kings disease too he's like
kicks out brutally show growth you know
obviously i'm super nice fan boy that's
that's the homie from the beginning
since i heard bill matic and i think
cole put me on hell maddie he's the one
that put me on shout out to cobra but um
yeah so for me him being this top
lyricist and then
you know seeing the growth like king
said which is there's always this
unwritten rule as the lyricist like you
don't never put too many dudes when
you're joining
because i gotta be the alpha and omega
when you put some really dudes that you
know is under you yeah you know i'm
saying so to him first to get m is a big
deal damn did his thing on that by the
way
amazing yeah the epmd2 joint with m and
um nas m and on epmd the og's that was
fire i love nobody with lauren he got
lauren to come out the house so
lauren hill
that's great like she doesn't that's
tremendous respect for her to even do a
trap and you know she she did she did
she had you know what i'm saying he had
to dispel a lot of rumors there and a
lot of uh prejudices that people have
because this industry gobbles people up
and spits him out in a manner that is
disgusting and we always form uh one
uh on
how can i say the the the the opinions
that we form about people's uneducated
opinions that we form about people based
on
information that we're yeah yeah that
we're family yeah and yeah you know to
label someone crazy and stuff like that
it's it's a big stigma and these people
can't recover from it and for him to
approach her and and respect her as a
queen as she is
and to have her on that track showed uh
i just saw a different level of
knowledge like yeah
and i respected her for doing it because
she doesn't do that like she doesn't
like for her to do that that's
tremendous respect for him so yeah yeah
salute to that and the last one was on
death row east i like that track because
we got you know what i'm saying a lot of
backstory during the east coast west
coast the park knives join eric b you
know i'm saying creating that was going
to create that with sugar numb and
before he passed and all that so yeah
that's pretty much it
as far as the musical joint for this
year
all right cool so our next question is
from select bang double oh seven you
know him what's that and he from last
stand me he came over yes sir that's
fantastic to support um i want to ask
slash talk about people's mental health
especially during covet
if it has affected you or people you
know personally
and how or what you did or are doing to
help yourself or others i personally
have struggled and since october last
year been suffering with anxiety and
panic attacks and feel it could help
others to share experiences
yeah i can go first um this is real this
is real man i like shot sled man i like
him um
for me you know gaming and working out
is super critical you know what i mean
for the mental health the anxiety the
depression
god goes through it too
you know so it's like it's real so i
think the first thing too is during the
pandemic
is always doing that checking on
somebody right yo yo what's up i hear
from you in a minute you know what i'm
saying yo what's going on you know what
i'm saying like you shoot your boy
message whatever whatever obviously
solve you know i'm saying yo what's
going on you all right you know what i'm
saying just want to make sure king yo we
ain't talking to me yo let's you know
what i'm saying attic what's going on
bro what's you know you i had a crazy
year you know what i'm saying so it's
just like you know
i think what it is as men
we try to tough it out too much
i think we we have this skin it's like
we can't show no vulnerability we kind
of you know push through it's really our
fault that's just how it's just the way
we built like the number one answer
y'all might you know what i'm saying you
don't want to do be like nah yeah yeah
that was you know that level of uh stuff
was taught to us
like we we were bred in with that man
don't cry
um type of thing yeah
be strong be strong don't be a sucker
because you yeah his knee on the floor
and stuff like that and we treat men in
a different manner that we treat women
and it's always been like that um
and
the the way to covet has uh affected
people so i mean sorry guys no no no no
no i'll let you go go ahead i mean i've
i've went to therapy i didn't start a
therapy because of the stupid covert
stuff um but um i'm a manager of uh two
wives so
in in managing um people emotions
because what what uh what a father what
a good a father what a good husband does
uh he manages uh that encampment
the the woman is the
the essence the earth
uh she nurtures it
what what what what the father does is
you know he he hunts gathers brings in
manages and also looks at every
individual now who's looking in on the
father's mental well-being during this
whole space and this whole time while
everybody is breaking down and
deteriorating in some form of fashion he
has to uplift he has to you know make
sure that people are doing well he has
to provide uh different venues for them
to have an outlet but there's no one
looking back at him
so in these moments you have to have a
good base a good basis your friends a
foundation uh your home unit uh and also
a good mental base to understand that
you can't control everything yourself
and you need absolute help on the
outside uh i can um attest to his uh
dealing with anxieties um i lost two
companies
and when you go from
making eight grand every week to every
two weeks making uh
probably eighteen hundred um
there's a drastic change yeah there's a
drastic change there's an absolute life
shift but coming from nothing uh coming
from ramen noodles coming from fat back
coming from uh
living in the projects uh you know with
food stamps and stuff like that i didn't
have a sense of fear for myself
my fear was for the individuals around
me that didn't grow up in those
circumstances you understand because in
those circumstances i can thrive i'm
pretty good i can i'm a minimalist at uh
everybody probably feels that i'm an
elitist but i'm not i'm a minimalist all
this material stuff means absolutely
nothing all it does was it just
strengthens my hard work when i look at
it that's all it's there for it's for
nothing else other than you worked hard
you played hard work on you but at the
end of the day all that stuff can go
away who are you at your core right so
you have to devolve yourself back to
your essence and you have to use that
essence to hold tight to that part so um
in going to therapy you start to break
down the barriers and the walls and
stuff like that and you know sovereign
said a lot of things that earlier today
as far as that putting the mirror within
yourself giving affirmations to yourself
and reflecting in upon yourself i tried
to tweet those things out to individuals
sometimes who don't have the 50 60 to go
sit down for a 45 minutes therapy
session
and to to to get into agreements with
yourself to be impeccable to be better
to have integrity to have stuff like
that to not give up on your dreams and
your hopes and stuff like that to stay
true to yourself to keep talking to
yourself to keep bigging yourself up
because there are hurtful words that are
being said easily
and not enough loving words that are
being said facts
right so we say hurtful things to each
other but we don't big each other we
don't never yeah yo you built that yeah
that's important that's the point i just
want to finish by joining because he was
on fire no i mean that's why the call i
mean the gaming are we we went into the
co-op aspect of gaming too because you
know i think that don't get me wrong i
like to get my single player on and all
that like saw you know i know that you
know but it's like at the end of the day
like it is important to get out of the
isolation bag sometimes
and just because sometimes i'm like i
don't feel like i just won't be alone
leave me alone
but then there's other times where i
just don't do it and i'm like when i
push myself and force myself faster even
when we do stuff together like to see
these feel like stuff together like
planning stuff together is important
especially during a pandemic because
then when you push yourself to get out
your comfort zone and you do it yo you
know what that was mad fun i got to
interact with my brothers and be bugged
out and chaotic talking about cap
over here
it was like
i had to force myself you know what i'm
saying and the last thing you already
know with me with the um the health is
wealth joint because i feel
physically you got to feel better about
yourself as well and that coincidence
helps the mental stuff yes you feel
better about yourself and you're doing
healthy you know that that's not pretty
much it but yeah it's a good question to
let anybody else want to go
oh yeah for me
um
you guys know that for me i'm generally
the one that you know
you got to sort of it's like pulling
teeth sometimes because i i don't know
you guys talk a lot you know every day
and it'll be you know you guys are
talking to me once a week
i said whatever he called me on the
phone
calls me
that thing where i i'm i'm usually i'm
pretty good about you know handling
stuff and and thankfully you know i
don't have a lot of drama around me
right my day-to-day life is is is great
you know so i can't complain about that
and then when there is drama i've
learned to be able to be i used to be
very
apathetic towards other people's issues
because i didn't have those issues and
then growing up you realize no you can't
be that way especially with people that
are close to you that have these issues
you have to be you have to be there for
them and and and in doing that you
understand you get to know that you
yourself aren't perfect and you can't
handle all these things perfectly as
perfectly as you think you do
um so for me
the the pandemic was weird in that
thankfully i didn't lose anything in
terms of work right so monetarily i
wasn't affected i was in certain
instances i did actually better than i
had been doing before so i had that
stability which was good but what was
scary about it is that at a time when
everybody was staying home beginning to
stay home and not going anywhere
i was out there every single day yeah i
was worried about you with that and that
was difficult because when you look to
the people that are supposed to have the
answers about what's going on and they
don't have the answers
everybody's winging it so i'm out there
and i'm like
i'm exposing myself every single day
because i have to
and then i'm bringing that home every
day and i don't know what to do to
protect the people around me and and you
guys remember i talked to you about how
my family was handling like my parents
and my brother and whatever that i had
to have i had to have a few very strong
conversations with family members
because they weren't being they weren't
taking it as serious as it needed to be
and it was a process to get them to
understand and unfortunately for for
most of them getting them to understand
was having someone
close close to them or that they knew
right
get very sick and pass away
for them to really really understand the
gravity of the situation the point
that's a valid point so um
so for me in that regard mentally
that was that was the most stressful
aspect of it the fact that going out
every single day not knowing exactly
what i had to do to protect myself and
protect the people around me and sort of
figuring it out on the fly
and um the podcast every week helped
with just being able to sort of
alleviate that right just to talk to my
homies every single day and be in person
uh we can't go to the movies like we
have been
we have that um but in other aspects it
also did help me i know a lot of people
suffered through like you know
relationship woes during that that point
in time
but for me as someone who's always out
and always working
during the course of the week my wife
and i don't see each other very much at
all now during the pandemic i like i
said i monetarily i wasn't affected but
i did work less hours right there was
just less work to be done right i was
just still getting paid thankfully so i
got to spend more time at home and for
some people obviously you know there was
a lot of sort of data indicating that
you know for people being forced in at
home like a lot of ugly stuff came out
but for my wife and i we took the
opportunity to be like wow we haven't
had this pretty much ever
ever since we've been married so in that
regard it strengthened our relationship
yeah so um again but that's a that's a
positive i got out of it um but in total
it's just it's one of those things where
it's made me
completely sympathetic to
people's the way people different people
deal with different things differently
yeah um and
people that you look at and you see as
these strong individuals
when put in this situation that has
never before been seen right by our
generation
how do you handle it and how can you
help them get past it and
what i hope is that at the end of this
whenever the end of this is if there
ever is an end of this
that we come out of it on the other side
just more willing to be to to be
understanding of other people's plights
and how
how they deal with it because we've been
through it as well so
i don't know and that's what i've gotten
from it man i honestly i'm just glad
that at the end of the day so far the
people that are closest to me that
family wise everywhere um and family and
friends have been able to stay
relatively safe no doubt attic what you
got
so i got
i got an idonic memory i don't know
people know what that is but it's like
if i'm if i go and like i don't forget
anything in terms of like
what i see
and
i tend to
that's what i'm looking for
i'll connect like
certain scenarios to what i see okay so
like like the problem is is like you
know
i got bad stuff that happened to me when
i was you know in my teens in my early
20s and it wouldn't be so bad
but i have an idonic memory
so it's like it never leaves yeah
so uh you know i there's certain
scenarios where if i hear if if i see a
certain shade of color
it it it takes me to certain places like
i i've literally been in houses one time
and i can like
every house i've ever been into i don't
remember i remember what it looks like i
remember the layout of the house
i remember where everything is in the
house i remember the driveway i remember
what color the the
the shed is
and like that's always like because
my mental
health
was [ __ ] before the pandemic and the
[ __ ] after and i'm working on it
but it's just like
when you have that kind of memory it's
hard to shake it yep
yeah it smells like like a smeller
transports you back to a space i think
that's probably one of the reasons i
don't i don't i don't mess with music
much oh okay
because i can't link that [ __ ] to
nothing i ain't i refuse to
so it's just like you know and then i
got ocd like i was telling cognito like
my ocd so bad i can't let
volumes end on a five or a zero like
it's got to be a five or a zero or the
whole time i'm watching that tv show my
mind is like that's on a three man
on an even number
it can't even end on any number it's got
to end on a five or a zero so if it's
like a 47 and as loud as hell i got to
bring that down to a 45 or two oh and
okay
i get it yeah yeah you know
you know i feel like youtube helped a
little bit because like
the only way i can escape it is if i
make myself busy
but then i have adhd so it's hard to
keep my mind on one thing
so it it it's it's it's it's been a time
man my life's been a time yeah no you
went through a lot by the way
to be able to express it and to talk it
and to verbalize it is actually a huge
step well i've always been decent at
communication and not any kind of form
but
not me and not at all
like you know especially when people
tell you
uh
the wildest thing i've ever heard by
people that i love is actually oh you
don't take responsibility
i've been taking responsibility since i
was [ __ ] nine years old
when i was nine years old going out and
getting rent money not knowing that i'm
paying rent money at nine years old
when i was uh getting my younger sister
dressed to school
braiding her hair at the age of [ __ ]
12 years old i was taking responsibility
then
when
my children
take the train or a bus and they think
it's a field trip
because they have been in the car their
whole damn life
i've been taking responsibility then
when i'm not with my firstborn children
but paying my child support never missed
and that was like an accomplishment when
child support tells you okay you don't
have to send no more uh here's the money
that you send extra back to you
that's taking responsibility when i
don't go off the handle on some stuff
that i'm feeling that i'm being
persecuted over but knowing that these
people are in the wrong but i'm taking
the high road that's taking
responsibility so
when individuals like try to undermine
your mental capacity and try to bring
you down trust me you shut down you
start to break down inside you don't
verbalize it so my problem was i was
never speaking at it i was just holding
stuff inside if there is a person that
pisses me off more it's a person that
wants you to validate they mental [ __ ]
but when you tell them yours they don't
validate they don't validate like oh no
that that that's unreasonable okay
okay stacy
i mean both of y'all i think are very
similar in that regard as far as
possibility i mean not put adjustments
out there obviously we have a brother
you know and i know how much
responsibility you have and you know
those are things that impressed me about
both of you two because you know
i never had that right so i never i
don't know what that is like to be that
young and to have to basically be a man
of the house and like at such a young
age right
and and that's that's that's that's
different man so yeah shout out to both
y'all for sure that because that's
something about both of you guys i
respect like that is a lot of
responsibility and what it is it takes
away in my opinion it takes away from
the youth
that you are afforded to enjoy
that time you know what i'm saying and
that's why i'm very both of you when i
talked
to i felt more comfortable staying at a
guaranteed job because i didn't want to
pursue anything because i i i i had to
meet ends meet with a mom
brother
i got so much
you don't have no idea how much respect
i have for you because
yeah when people people that don't know
you and the same thing like they don't
know king they don't know you and it's
just like
like when if they i'll never give that
information up unless you give me
permission to but if they truly knew
you both are amazing at what you've
survived and been through and i got you
my brothers i guess respect i got
respect not that i don't have respect
for so i just died
but it's different like you and i
thankfully i mean you and i we didn't
have that situation you know my parents
were both there my dad was a very
responsible dad like i i had that
childhood i had that childhood without
having that burden of having to to be a
caretaker of of a child
me being a child as well like i didn't
even have that different that is
completely different and it's gonna it's
gonna skew how you think about
everything and like king said like it's
gonna teach you to to to internalize
everything right
so if there's anything we take from this
is that
talking about your issues with whomever
right either a stranger you know therapy
or your friends or whatever it doesn't
make you any less of a man
woman it doesn't make you crazy it makes
you human human and
honestly like i if this one if there's a
thing that you i think about as i've
grown up and and and and consider myself
more mature
it is the idea of letting go of any sort
of pride you may have about what you
hold close to the chest
and letting it go completely because
you're not the only one that's going
through it and there's there's gonna be
people out there that be able to listen
to you and help you whether it's your
friends your family or or therapy or
whatever the case may be
and we're all better for it like we're
all better forward couldn't have said it
better myself all righty so
any anything else on that no no no no no
we're good
all right so i believe this is the final
question and this is from tao i don't
know if this is tauz uichi i think it
would be dta that's wichi because okay
that's his short name for on our patreon
okay so then we had
i would like to know the lord's favorite
gaming genre and a favorite memory or
experience tied to it you guys always
going to people's history
would like to know the lords
who
my mind is fighting
damn it
too yeah absolutely fighting everything
that we have is tied to some form of
combat
form of
last man standing
it's always been
the verses it's it's and i'm not gonna
say it because you know i put halo into
the verses i put uh anything that is uh
is there but
it's one particular
game and it's got to be halo and it has
to be me versus mr how with the pistol
in here
hang in my iv
i remember that and i'm gonna tell you
man i remember that day like was
yesterday i smell the air i remember
everything and ha ha how was you know
how i was really good with this pistol
how i knew that he could double tap you
pull you down
and my thing was you know pistol
grenades i got you baby and i just have
a total belief in myself like my mental
is really really really strong when it
comes to the belief in myself and what i
feel i can do i knew how i was a
superior pistol guy i knew if i had line
of sight he gonna knock you straight
dead
um
and i knew this board was his board
um
and i took the challenge and i went in
there and we we locked in
and
i just knew if i could break him down
mentally
i can destroy him
and i got into it
got into his head it was something
stupid
but it was spider-man mm-hmm and i was
going dan and then
and that's when it started and then from
that moment i just started breaking him
down i threw the grenade can he swing
and i was bouncing grenades off the wall
and to see him devolve
from this confident strong juggernaut
into this whimpering dude with the
boogers in his nose and then
i didn't no this can't be happening
and after every kill you would do you
would say ass
yes i was like why are you saying this
because it had nothing to do i know
y'all did that always for basketball but
you did it you did it for after every
time you killed him manipulation yo my
god king
i had a really really bad problem when i
would play yugioh at competitions
like i remember i would get so cocky
with my friends that i would play with
that that like i one one time i
accidentally like i leaned too much over
and they saw my whole hand and they're
like they're like aj i can see your hand
i was like dude it don't matter and i
put my whole hand face up and i was like
you could see the whole thing i was like
it doesn't matter you're still gonna
lose
i still won i still won like
like
it was i don't the the biggest time that
i will never forget is me and mike we
went to a region it was like three hours
away
and me and my cousin storm was talking
so much [ __ ]
and i i i would never forget this is the
only time this dude has ever beat me i
will be here 100 times and he'll beat me
once and i talk [ __ ] about we talk [ __ ]
the whole way there we get there because
it was like i think 700 people yeah and
they matched us in the first round
and i was sitting up like hey and i
remember i sat down i was like storm
easy pass for me and might as well not
even like i kid you i probably beat this
dude a hundred times the night the day
before do beat me 2-0 and i was so upset
i remember i sat there
and this i will never forget storm was
like because you got to sign the piece
of paper
and he puts it on my side of the table
he's like he's like you go sign that bro
yo you gotta fight you gotta [ __ ]
you gotta fight
until this day every time i'm like dude
you you was always trashy you because we
don't play it anymore he's like yeah but
i beat you at that region
i gotta i gotta jump right because
i know what haddock talked about because
um
we all know that king knows
like fighting games tekken that was that
was the thing tekken was life
and tekken we learned a lot of life
lessons a second
you know saying between the having the
metro fortitude to deal with king
and the the suits and the and the the
talking and the tiger with the disco
ball
you just don't want to lose to him and
you got that and then solve with the
tactician oh no you don't want to lose
because you don't want to lose you don't
want to lose because you want to hear
their mouth the mouth right so can you
lose
like a such a tactician and when he gets
in his bag it gets frustrating you know
saying with the frame dead and stuff but
i got to shout out cassava's brother
people don't realize like
he
he was my
dojo like he was the student for me
right i wanted to build him to make him
into something
and i'll never forget this day at it we
did the tournament
and what we do is we lock ourselves in a
room right and it's just you who
131 whoever beats each other to get a 10
fight win
and the day he beat me
and i came out the rumor can't say yeah
what happened i was like
i was so embarrassed
to say that man elevate it past me
you know what's crazy
i traveled to get my l
i traveled three hours i'm just sitting
there
uh i'm sitting there
i got this piece of paper in my front of
my face and i'm just thinking myself
what went wrong
you start you start digging deep into
that like what what's wrong what's funny
is like like
like because it was a swiss round that
means you still play all your rounds it
doesn't matter so i went like eight and
two he went one and seven so you was the
only one
yo so like when cog came out the room
in my head i said oh he dusted jamie
in my head i was like he got kaibabs he
mixed them up and jamie came out with
this dominant face
jb i remember jamie coming out almost
embarrassed
you don't understand like in my hey i
was that dude i didn't lose those type
of things
i actually cuz i don't do like a i don't
do fighters but my friend ronnie and my
friend jared does fighters and ronnie's
one of those people he just plays his
friends he never plays online
so so he's thinking he'd think he a
beast right so jared jared's played
professionally i had to add fights and
mortal kombat says gabe and ronnie's
like well i got you
and like jared washed him like 6-0 and
then and then and he's like dude
i'm done and jay's like i'll beat you
blindfolded you just have to tell me
what side of the map you want wow and
he's like you ain't doing that jared
washed him 6-0 blindfolded that's crazy
we used to do great stuff too but i mean
like yeah when i came out there
yeah i came back to the room and i was
just like because what it was is with
jamie
i always knew what i had to do to get
him off his squabble
right and he finally developed the
mental toughness to not fall for my
tricks to not fall for my mouth or
anything like i didn't really i had
bought for him because i just tried to
do i learned from king certain things
that i knew could bother so once i once
you heard that grunt from davey i got
satisfied yes
but none of it worked
and that man studied me
so proficiently every pattern every flow
i mean he was blocking things attic that
i was throwing the kitchen sink at him
with mix-ups and timings and frame data
and he blocked and what i learned that
day
is never
get complacent with patterns and
repeating and ego because if you think
you so nice that that person like he he
taught me oh no no you better mix things
up all the time even if you know you
have somebody that they can't defend
something specifically don't show it all
the time that's the first thing i
learned doing anything competitively
especially
like
when i play like you you'll learn like
real quick would you play with people in
that game like like you got to talk like
you like a lot of people the people lose
that though they won't talk they'll just
they'll just play but the people that
winnie
they can talk and still
fight at this point so they're throwing
them off game because they don't want to
be rude so they're talking to you and
it's like man like there's there's a lot
of little things in any competition that
would just throw people off
that day would rob
that's when i knew all right i got to go
practice
they got the book
they got
[Applause]
ironically me and king both picked you
chihuahuas so they have like this this
uber form
well
it was one to one
and we uh what's funny is like we both
went into our he went into his second
form and he started dashing at me
and i just got the the good end of this
thing because i picked the rage on so i
went into mine and like i literally just
kept shooting him over and over again
and he couldn't get close to me he's
like this is [ __ ]
yeah but he's not telling you who won
i won that was two to one no i'll be
trying oh here we go here we go
if you got that photographic memory i
want you to dig deep into your right
hand
don't surprise
[Laughter]
it was a very low point so
it was it was i could not believe i lost
i was it was embarrassing
and yeah he had that title you know what
i said and i go front like
it made me a better person because it
took everything in my power the next
tournament for me to beat him you know
what i'm saying and um to get it back
you know and i was proud of myself but
shout out to him like he he became
something demonic engaged that's what we
called tomorrow
you know your brother he's a savant man
he's a savant it's funny because
my story my story always comes back to a
king thing it's always a king thing
because we were we were we were always
super competitive right mm-hmm
but not to the level that it got to when
king became part of the group when kim
became part of the group
so it became a thing like if you could
beat king
then it would it was a very yeah
that was a stamp because it was hard to
be there
it was hard to beat him back he was he
was playing his mental games and then he
wasn't a scrub he wasn't it was nice
yeah like it was right and he could talk
at the same time
exactly so again so going back to like
the question fighting games is what we
came from so if i want to say that's my
favorite genre i don't
i'm not in it like we used to be
but it it's where we came from if i if i
would say my comfort food right now i
think it's like like an open world like
that's my comfort world but but to to
speak on the fighting game thing like
again king elevated the group to another
level and we grew up as men in a lot of
ways yeah
those interactions
i specifically remember
there was a point where where cog
kaibatu and myself
we were in the dojo every single day
like it was after work come out mojo it
was so we got to the point that we
elevated beyond
everybody else in the group for there
was a period of time there was nobody
else in the group could touch us
and so it and it was cog number one
i bought two number two and me number
three right and we used to do the
ranking yeah we created this hierarchy
right so for wow
that they call them nobody wanted to be
in the box i mean we call you the box
you're the worst of the crew you the
beautiful
it was still sharp and steel
did not want to be caught in these
positions
so king but again king is king king
there was a while the king wasn't really
hanging with us all that often like he
was he wasn't hanging regularly around
sometimes he really he was out of the
tekken loop right he came in king being
king yeah he was like i gotcha so he he
immediately went to cog right mm-hmm i
remember kyle being like no there's a
hierarchy yeah like you can't you're
you're not you're not playing
so he's like you got to play you got to
play solve because
in terms of who's in the house the
ranking is hit
so and then cogs like you're not beating
him
so we went in and king was talking bad
smell right
so
i just remember
that we went in i was playing as brian
fear at that time i was going back and
forth too brian fury
and so
i learned again
from playing with kai batu so much
playing with cogs so much that is like
take your time to to watch your opponent
and recognize patterns and don't don't
sweat it don't sweat it
so i'm in there and king dusts me
for four matches straight
four matches they're talking smack to me
obviously with tiger
the point i think the last match the
last match he double perfected me right
yes
so at that moment
right any any any normal person you look
at them be like i've broken him right
i turned the king
as calmly as i am right now and i said
to him
you're done
[Laughter]
i said you're done i solved you you're
not going to wait
to say that yes
yo where you go
when
imagine for king who hasn't been kind of
around us for a while right
and i don't care how confident you are
and for me to have the audacity to look
at him and be like and i said you're not
winning another round
and so it was
so good it was one of those things
at that point right brian fury has a
sweep kick that juggles you right
and it it goes through anything if i
catch you i'm gonna juggle okay so every
time i would hit king with that
i would say
like i would do like batman sound
effects
so we didn't we didn't finish the whole
thing like we did like four or five more
matches and he didn't win another break
but but again it's that thing where i
don't learn that confidence right
myself and kai there was competition
it was more general yeah we were more
gentlemen like and then here he come
and he wow
you
nothing worse than being beat by him
because not only is he good he can talk
and be good then he's got the crowd
around him and he's so naturally funny
and everyone's laughing at you
so now it puts more pressure on you
and once he got if he see a [ __ ] and
your armor is over it's over he's going
to keep punishing you and then you got
to deal with the mental effort and he
did that on dcx we had a dude that came
on and he started talking that street
fighter crap
i purchased the street fighter
collection i downloaded it got him on i
put the camera i took my phone out i
called everybody you see the chat that
says yeah you know the big d chat yeah i
put everybody put it on video and
everybody was able to watch oh that's
the other thing yeah yeah
i got i gotta cut you for a second
because that's the thing about you that
people don't realize is that
you forced us out of our comfort zone
because like we we're trying to keep it
gentlemanly in the corner no he learned
i learned how to perform on a big stage
yes
because i was very timid to to to do all
that with the big lights and everybody
around like you know
right now
you learned about right now right now
outside you you had that look like you
called me out
oh but you learned because it it helped
build you into being confident to
display your skills and now yeah and
that transcended and that transcended to
just you as a person yes i agree it
always did it always did i remember
specifically
just again king's influence i remember
like my brother started working out
doing boxing stuff and i remember i see
i i'll say this now right but when i was
younger
i always knew my brother was better at
me
at games always he always just watched
me in most things except i'm a street
fighter yes
so i forgot what the game was would play
it might have been taken right and i
always had a habit of like he beat me i
must him or like
i would slap him up yeah
so i remember uh he beat me at something
it was in cogs house
and
he had had enough
he drops the controller it starts to
strangle me like he's really mad at me
and then he's like oh no oh i was dead
oh yeah well y'all
the funny thing is it was there that i
learned to respect my brother
differently yes right when you're like
okay i forgot about it but i gotta ask
real quick i got that because addict is
dude
i know you and zach has a movement oh
one day come on down come on down really
zachary knows his place
see attic is way bigger than zachary and
stuff like that i don't know no i'm not
you're not he's like half an inch tall
shorter than me like okay so he's okay i
i i remember like the only time like
there's a bigger dude over him yeah the
only time that like i remember like
having something like that happen is
like i was playing cards with my friend
tyler and
he got mad because i beat him and he
threw his like
his yu-gi-oh deck at me and like keep in
mind like these these extra thousands of
dollars like they're not cheap like one
car could be like like three hundred
dollars you have to have three of them
so
he threw this stack at me and it's like
it's like a 900 deck i'm like oh thanks
man like he's like no no no i'm like no
you threw it at me man it's mine now
because he got mad because i beat him
but he threw it at me
and i was like and i just killed my
pocket walked out the door yeah
my thing is was to mentally physically
uh and emotionally build the men around
me yeah and uh jamie me me
me and jamie i took a special liking to
him so i would take him and david to the
boxing gym yeah and then we will go out
there we go to the track we'll lift
weights and stuff like that
he was in the best shape of his life
[Music]
and um i remember i i will never forget
that time that happened because he said
enough is enough
shout out to that
yo because you got to understand like as
we were growing up right it was it was i
was the oldest and then my sister and
then he's the youngest right so most of
the time like we weren't kids that were
allowed to be outside and stuff like
that so we always we played in the house
right so a lot of the times whether it
was baseball video games or whatever it
would be them two versus me right and i
was still big enough
over both of them that i could still
kind of smack them around so what i
would do a lot of the time
this is move that i caught i called it
the caliper caliper
and it was a ddt into the radiator
yo hee wild
and i would you know and you know when
you're young you don't have that thing
where it's like i'm gonna solve ddt you
know i'm gonna do the real thing i'm
like
so i used to like ddt him into the
radiator i used to do wrestling moves on
him that really hurt like stuff like
time this is years of abuse just coming
to the head in one vote thank you lisa
that's your limitation i did this one
time where uh nico it was kitsu's
birthday and uh i remember zachary
wanted to play him at halo
and i remember zachary's beating him so
bad i had to go in the other room and
tell him like yo let him kill you a
couple times it's his birthday
[Music]
my favorite genre is probably either
turn base or or
it's it's anything strategy wise if you
want to be
honest yeah the same thing addicts turn
based on the solo tip you know you know
how i mean you with that you know send
the tactical to the positioning and all
that the x-com and all that but
yes all i got with this uh round table
we gave you all that extended behind the
scenes for the patrons and the members
but uh any shout outs for the on the way
out with yo you guys want to get off
before we leave
it's going to be a hell of a man talk
tomorrow oh i felt that was coming yeah
i felt that was coming
keep in mind that um
the first one will go into um
i'm going to put it up on patreon a
members for like a couple days and then
put it public because i do want to give
the because i do want the first one to
go public just to give a feel of what we
did yeah i feel you saying yeah give us
i do want to give the patreons and the
members a couple days at advance
it was their questions yeah no doubt so
they solve anything we'll say to the
people ah man a big shout out to attic
for putting this together uh this is
cool uh obviously you get to see us in a
little bit of a different light uh i
like the personal questions i i'm the
kind of the dude like i
i i've gotten better being kind of an
open book so you know whatever
let the questions rip i don't really
mind
you can get into deep subjects and stuff
like that it's cool no no so that's all
we got i guess r and r a round table
whatever we call it yeah we got to
figure out whatever the name we called
it you know what i'm saying but yo
everybody enjoyed it we will be in the
realm tomorrow this is recorded on a
saturday and uh we out peace